[Music]
little lights studi content creator
Mikey Jenny joins a wolf in sheep's
clothing to give his testimony on how
media introduced him to the occult
welcome brother Mikey thank you it's
such a privilege to be here we're so
glad you made it we want to start with
your childhood so yeah I was raised in a
a typical Baptist Home you know I grew
up knowing about God and his son died
for my sins I went to VBS um there was
something called AAS that I went to so
my parents did the best they could to
teach me about the Bible and um at about
age nine I guess I kind of reached an
age of accountability where I I was
alone in a car one day my mom was
transcribing the pastor's sermon and I
was just out there alone with my
thoughts and I realized I'm a sinner at
that point I had already lied I'd stolen
I'd you know done broke the
Commandments and I just realized that
I'm a sinner that needs a savior and I
knew that the only way to get to God was
through Jesus and so at that moment I
accepted Christ Christ I even cried a
little bit and I told my mom and shortly
after that I was getting baptized into
the church and um started going to these
youth groups and we we had branched out
from Baptist to more charismatic Word of
Faith so we were going to these a little
more Wilder churches and at the youth
group there was all these I was
surrounded by older teens that I looked
up to and they were going on mission
trips and things like that and then I
started to just have these kind of
skeptical thoughts in my mind um you
know I started to be seduced by the
things on TV that I was you my parents
they they said we're not going to watch
certain things we're not going to watch
you know MTV and things like that and
violent video games were starting to
come out and they were trying to shelter
me from those things but I had reached
an age where I could stay the night at
friends houses or stay home when they
went to the store and so my my curiosity
you know I started watching those things
and I can look back on that and see that
that's really where
I got derailed you know the things that
I was being exposed to really did have
an impact in my life it's interesting
because the age of accountability the
Bible speaks about that and it was
impressed upon you that you needed to
make a decision for Christ and at the
same time temptation is sneaking in so
now you're deciding between which God do
I serve right so how did that take a
turn yeah it's interesting to mention
that CU you know I wasn't pressured into
it it wasn't somebody saying you know
say these words after me it was just me
and God so I do feel like I had had an
experience with God but like you said
Temptation came along and so I began to
play these violent video games and they
felt fun and then I'd you know my
parents would leave and I'd turn on MTV
and I'd see these wild parties and bands
on stage and and you know just people
having fun at the beach and I started
thinking you know I knew that that's not
an environment that a Christian should
be at and so then I started thinking as
is this all Christianity is about like
everything fun is bad right so that's
what I was dealing with and I've always
my whole life I've been a truth Seeker
my whole life I I I was trying to find
the
truth and I and I was I'm a skeptic
truth
seeking and so I started to think
skeptical about the thoughts the things
that I was raised on I was like I
started having tough questions and I
would ask the pastor or whoever you know
if God said don't Thou shalt not kill
why do you murder the entire world MH
and I just started having these tough
questions and I think I really had those
questions because well he did did save
eight that's right right and now I look
at that you know that was an act of
Mercy on those eight if he wouldn't have
saved those eight they would have been
murdered by everyone else but I wasn't
getting responses like that you know the
church really dropped the ball on giving
me the answers to my tough questions and
I would get answers like well some
things we just won't know till we get to
heaven and to me that just seemed like a
cop out I'm like these are the people
that are supposed to have the answers
that I'm looking for the thing that you
bring out in this that I'm hearing is
that basically everyone relegates one
day of Holiness and they say or even
just one hour of Holiness right because
different people have a different
opinion on how they should observe the
sabbath some people think it's Sabbath
some people think it's you know Sunday
but in actuality the Bible says the
seventh day Sabbath but what he calls us
to do is to be holy all those days but
that one day we worship him so it seems
also that you know we emulate whatever
our environment is and although we just
give one day to God every day is
supposed to be a walk with him that's
right and so you were separating the day
and the spirit in which you were serving
him and it allowed the enemy to come in
yeah so what in particular had just
really caressed your mind and this and
bathed it in no no no you need more of
this and not God yeah so I I think the
reason I started having these skeptical
thoughts was because something in me
wanted to have the the world it looked
fun and I wanted to justify that and so
I started asking these tough questions
but like I said I didn't I wasn't
getting good answers and then one day I
was I turned on MTV and this man named
Marilyn Manson came on the screen
familiar with him yeah yeah something
immediately I was gravitated towards him
when I saw him I was like that's exactly
what who I want to be and I don't know
why but this was at age 11 or 12 so I
went from like being eight or nine to a
short few years later and I mean during
that time I had a good Christian walk I
was going to these youth groups I had
burnt comic books that I had and you
know I was surrounded by godly people
but it was an exterior experience Y and
as the media kept showing me things that
looked fun because Satan loves to
package everything in a in a fun package
he has a a tackle box full of bait for
everybody oh you're not into the occult
what about the new age you know it's all
about light and love and colors you know
so he has a way to get you no matter
what you're into well he watches and
studies so he watched you playing these
video games and he noticed when your PE
your P pupils dilated he noticed when
your heart started to have a different
rhythm and so he says oh he likes that
package Marilyn Manson that's who I'll
send that's right and so right when I
seen him you know people ask me all the
time like what what made that happen
what made you like gravitate towards
this guy I don't know we're we're
naturally born into this sinful flesh
you know our our flesh is at enmity with
God and something about even even before
that I remember talk shows where parents
would have their Gothic teens come out
and there was something about me that
liked that
style and so
yeah I just started to go through this
hard heart I started having this hard
heart I was going through the motions at
that point I had to go to church cuz my
parents did and so by age 12 I was
totally checked out I was like so were
you basically representing Marilyn
Manson even at church you were like
completely goth at that time I was too
young to to my parents wouldn't let me
do it you know they're not going to buy
clothes that I that I liked or whatever
I had so you were secretly emulating him
in your heart yeah and then
with one day hoping once I'm independent
enough I I'm going to expose my my true
nature yeah wow so I guess around age 13
or 14 is when your parents kind of feel
hopeless like they can't really control
everything you do and that's when I went
you know I had one of my ears pierced
and they said no you can't get your ears
pierced and and I would just come in the
living room and my eyebrow would be
pierced because I did it myself okay and
they're like well you know I I
understand the struggle with parents
because they don't want to be too
authorit you know they don't want you to
just act in Rebellion because they're
saying no so they kind of pull back the
reins a little bit but that's how I
started it acting out I would uh Pierce
parts of my body and stuff like that and
then a movie came out called the craft
you ever heard of it I have heard of it
and haven't seen it but tell us about it
so when that movie came out my parents
definitely didn't want me to see that
because it was blatant witchcraft I mean
it wasn't like Harry Potter that that
could be that could fall under fantasy
and it looks like a fairy tale and
people think H you know it's harmless M
but the craft was about four attractive
High School females that are getting
into Witchcraft and it looks real like
so they packaged it in Beauty yes for
hot girls so to speak exactly and so as
a you know a teenage male of course I I
liked what I was seeing and then they're
doing all these things like binding
spells and Voodoo and they're making the
guy they like fall in love with them
they're changing the color of their hair
by just you know wiping their hands over
it or making the red light turned green
as they continue driving and that stuff
looked cool because that was like this
is real life I can I can alter the
elements around me and there's a power
to that and we all kind of have this
desire for power to control things the
way you want and so the internet was
relatively new back then I was in high
school there wasn't things like Facebook
or anything like that not even YouTube
but I started going on these message
boards these forums and I started
looking into like is there anything true
about this witchcraft you know and so I
would read people's experiences their
testimonies it's like Satan has a
counterfeit for everything we we're
sharing our testimony about how God
changed our life they're sharing their
testimony about how they got this power
and how these tarot cards work and Ouija
boards and all that and those are the
types of questions I had as a kid I
remember there was a game day and a girl
asked if she could bring a Ouija board
and the teacher said no and I asked my
mom what's a Ouija board I don't even
know what that is and she goes oh it's
you know it's something bad I don't know
it's evil and I'm like what's wrong with
it I don't know I just heard it was bad
so that's the kind of responses I was
always getting I was always like I don't
know why it's bad it's just bad so you
wanted to test the spirit yourself
exactly instead of measuring it against
the Bible you started to say no I just
want to put my own intuition my own
heart into it and discern it for myself
yeah I I even today I believe that we
shouldn't be afraid of looking at
evidence to me I believe that the Bible
is is 100% truth and it can it can
debunk all this stuff and so I even
looked in the evolution and all that and
you when you when you look at that stuff
realistically it it goes completely
against science and so I I think that as
Christians we should be ready always to
give an answer to those who have
questions you know and we're growing up
in a world of a lot of Skeptics
especially the young people they want
answers for things and if the church
doesn't have the answers or we're afraid
to talk about it we're going to lose
them that's true and for me me I was
attracted to the Paranormal I was
attracted I I would even in elementary
school I went to a public school and
there would be books on the shelves
about pictures of ghosts pictures of
aliens and UFOs and and it wasn't
Goosebumps or whatever it was like real
photographs and so I was intrigued by
that I it was this mystery that I wanted
to know about and and the church didn't
have the answers for that either so the
darkness is calling you deeper and
deeper in what happened to your
character and and what did you end up
saying these are new aspirations how did
that play out well yeah because I wasn't
getting answers about what these things
were I was like I'm going to find out
because I was a truth Seeker so I'd
begin to think that the church was
really narrow-minded and if they didn't
understand it it must be evil or of the
devil and so I just I started doing
things like ghost hunting like going out
in the graveyards at night and trying to
see things and people would tell me oh
if you go down this dirt road and park
your car and turn the lights off there's
like a lantern that'll come and I did
all that stuff because I was looking for
it and uh I really think that God had
his hand over me I think that he
protected me from seeing anything
because if I would have seen something
like that I would have said this is
truth but my mom was definitely praying
for me every night and so I would start
playing around Ouija boards A friend
gave me one and he'd tell me all this
stuff about it like yeah we you know I
tried to get rid of it and I couldn't I
tried to throw it away and it ended up
on my bed again and so I'm giving it to
you and like that intrigued me and yet
every time I play with it nothing would
happen i' I'd take it to a friend's
house and I'd see them put their hands
on it and move around and I'd say let me
get on there and nothing would happen
intercessory prayer intercessory prayer
I believe 100% that's what was happening
because there is power to these things
it's not just toys you know there's no
power in a a cardboard board game right
but when you pull that out you're
telling the spirit world I'm inviting
you to show me something AB absolutely
yeah and so that's what people need to
understand when you you're giving
consent you're just by engaging in it
you give the authority and the legal
right for them to come and invade your
space and even your body that's right
cuz Satan he he can't he doesn't have
the authority to come into your space
but there I think there's a lot of
things we do that invite him in
unknowingly if you put a Buddha statue
in your house because you got you saw it
it looked fashionable right that's an
invitation when you go shopping for
furniture it's it's everywhere literally
everywhere I made that mistake as well
you know I I put in a what looked like a
beautiful statue in my house and when
God showed me you know this is not of me
I threw it out I wish I had burned it
because within 10 minutes of me setting
it out someone had come and taken it got
it yeah yeah yeah and the Bible does
encourage us to burn those things for
that reason but I was uh I was getting
drawn to dark imagery so I started
wearing a pentagram you know I I just
had a um you were asking about my
character I wanted to be shocking I
wanted to shock the world when I saw
Marilyn Manson he was what they call a
shock rocker and so I wanted to one up
him I wanted to and he would tear up
Bibles on stage so to me I ended up
moving to to South Georgia when I was in
high school and I met another friend
that was like me in that area there's a
lot of it's a small town there wasn't a
whole lot of people like me but me and
this guy became best friends and we
started making music together and we
refused to make music unless we're
intoxicated and mainly on marij
um so we would you know if we didn't
have it we were doing everything we
could to get it mowing lawns or whatever
and then we would get the marijuana we
would smoke and get high and then he
would play the guitar and then I would
freestyle and music would just come out
of me words would come out of me that
rhymed it made sense it was just flowing
without me even thinking and most of the
time it was Blasphemous and one of the
you know the songs I was most proud of
mocked the
crucifixion and I look back on that and
I'm like I don't have the ability to do
that now I mean if somebody plays a
guitar it I can't just flow and music
come out of me and I truly believe that
I was opening myself up with wearing
pentagrams having black candles all
these things that I was decorating my
room with that were blatantly evil I
wasn't even it wasn't even like a little
Buddha statue or something right it was
blatantly occult stuff well the Bible
tells us by beholding you become change
and so as a man thinketh so he is right
so this is really who you are so now
you're babbling in music where did your
music career take you well at that time
it was kind of just a underground
project thing and and like I said this
stuff was just coming out of me and I
can look back and and realize that when
you're messing around with marijuana
drinking Spirits they call it these
things for a reason you know Native
Americans they would smoke things as a
spiritual thing we do it as Recreation
or social but it's it's not it's a
spiritual thing um I eventually had
moved away from that town and came back
to Chattanooga and that's where I kind
of reached a rock bottom and was looking
for God at that point everything that I
was going for was a hopeless dead end it
was you know I was I was looking for
peace I was plagued with the idea that
one day I'm going to I'm going to be
dead one day I'm going to die no matter
what I do I could be the biggest rocket
scientist or brain surgeon or I could be
a jail bird my whole life if the
ultimate end is death it doesn't matter
what I do and so I was like what is the
point why am I here I never asked to be
born I never asked to be face all these
decisions who will you serve and your
whole eternity depends on it and so I
was plagued with this thought and I was
just running from that through drugs
alcohol every lust of the flesh that I
could and then my parents got a divorce
and me and my Dad decided to move back
to Chattanooga and my cousin drove five
hours to help us move because he had a
truck and uh I found out that this was
my older cooler cousin I looked up to
and he had just become a Christian and I
heard him sharing his testimony with my
mom and it intrigued me and so on the
drive back it was just me and him in the
small cab of his truck and he was trying
to reach me where I was and I think you
know there God has a million different
ways to reach people he's such a
personal God he he's going to reach me
different than he's going to reach
somebody else he's going to in the same
way that the devil tempts us studies us
and knows what our predilections are God
also knows us he created us he knows how
our life will end because he started it
all so he working on you yeah and so you
know where I wasn't and that's what my
mom was praying my mom's specific prayer
was every night she was praying for me
Lord don't let my son die and go to hell
like do something and she realized that
anytime she tried to witness to me
herself it just pushed me away anytime
she'd talk about her testimony it
literally made my skin crawl and I'd
want to leave the room I was filled with
so many demons that the power of her
testimony repulsed me and so her prayers
began to change and she would say God
you send somebody that he's going to
listen to you send somebody that he
looks up to to witness to him and that
was my cousin and so he started showing
me he's like man this book isn't a book
of a bunch of old crusty rules he's like
it has the answers to life in it he said
I read it and and miracles happen around
he's like the whole atmosphere changes
he said it's kind of like that magic
stuff you're into so he was trying to
reach me where I was because he knew I
was dabbling in the occult and so he so
you were outward with your practice well
I couldn't hide it you know wearing
pentagram and these satanic shirts and
things and dying my hair black and all
that tattoos yeah starting to get into
that and um so our conversation really
intrigued me because what he said was
don't judge God by all the Hypocrites
that represent him and that really spoke
to me because I was judged every day for
the way I looked and people would always
say wow you're nothing like I thought
you'd be and I would always say oh you
judge me you know and I hated that so
God really used him to speak to me and
so when I moved to Chattanooga
I just opened up the Bible and I said
God if you're real reveal yourself to me
through this book like you did my cousin
I said he's got no reason to lie to me
about this stuff and I just started
reading and it was like I was seeing
things for the first time I grew up all
my life in church hearing Adam and Eve
and Daniel lion den and all these core
stories that we grew up on but the Bible
was an interesting book I was like whoa
I've never heard this just in the Book
of Genesis and so I began to pray a
specific prayer about a job that you can
only get this job if you know somebody
and so I kept turning applications never
getting the job and then I finally
reached a place where I just had to get
any job and the last place I applied for
was this
restaurant and when I started working
with the lady she was like oh my best
friend is the manager over there that
wasn't a coincidence no and to me three
months later I got this job that I was
wanting that I was Desiring and I wrote
for the first time I wrote God got me
the job I was looking for thank you
Jesus and I stuck it on a mirror in my
in my room so I went from being singing
songs of blasphemy to now I'm thanking
God for answering my prayer but and only
the Holy Spirit can do this in us it's
it's not because of our works it's
intercessory prayer yeah and I could
have said me I did it you know and it's
an honest you know inquiry into the Lord
Lord if you're real and when your heart
is sincere the Holy Spirit can feel it
that's exactly right yeah because I hear
atheists all the time like I've read
that book cover to cover there's all
these flaws and it's the spirit in which
you approach it yeah you're looking for
error you're not looking for truth and
my heart was at a place where I was like
God if you're real show yourself through
this and he did and I was still in a
place where I like I was like okay God I
I believe you're real I believe the
Bible I believe you're answering my
prayers but I'm not ready to become a
Christian yet I knew my whole life was
going to have to change and I was at a
place where I was uh I just turned 21 I
was in the
clubs and um I just felt like you know
on my deathbed I'll give my life to you
and like what a selfish motive we often
think that we often think and we risk it
because you don't get to decide the day
that you go and when you go that's the
day probation closes for you as an
individual that's right and so it's
better to live knowing or having that
hope and that faith and striving to
toward righteousness not saying you know
taking God for granted taking your life
for granted and saying uh you know when
I die I'll finally surrender it's not
how it works yeah and so I I continued
chasing after my dreams which was a
fashion designer I wanted to have my own
clothing line me and a friend started
rapping I did start my own clothing line
it was called execute
clothing and it seemed like the doors
were I believe the doors were
supernaturally being opened and my
cousin who inspired me to read the Bible
was even telling me I was blessed by God
because I wasn't reading it daily and
that's that's the thing we have to be in
that truth or we will fall for the
counterfeit hands down right in the same
way you're in your Wilderness walking if
we think back to the biblical Wilderness
the you know the Jews were called out
out of Egypt and as they walked in that
Wilderness God gave them what Mana daily
the bread so the Bible is the bread it
is the word and we must be in it daily
yeah yeah it's easy to get LED astray if
you just listen to man and so I was at a
place where the clothing line was
blowing up I mean I had models all over
the world wearing it California Spain
Australia I'd go to these concerts and
give a shirt to the lead singer and then
people would be lining up to buy the the
products and so then one day my friend
was like my my rap buddy he was like
let's go to Atlanta today just out of
nowhere just said let's go to Atlanta
okay cool bring my shirts I always
brought them I called the one person I
knew in Atlanta and she said come to
this address now and bring your shirts
and when I get there it's soldja boys
click is there having a photo shoot and
next thing I know they're all wearing my
my shirts getting pictures in them and
stuff you couldn't pay for that I know
and it was just happening and it was
almost like like being led by the Holy
Spirit but Satan's leading you because
I'm not walking with God the way I
should and all these Supernatural things
would happen so it got to the point
where me and my friend went to
California we were having a music video
shot everything was happening the we're
at a
mansion there's girls there's
alcohol and we shot this music video and
God was starting to he was he never gave
up on me God never gives up on me he's
always trying to get our attention but
he doesn't force himself upon us it's
that small still voice Satan's the one
that's using force and tricks and all
this but and I was a Believer but I
wasn't surrendered and so I kept chasing
this dream and next thing I know I'm in
the LAX Airport coming home and I bump
into soldja boy's CEO the manager and
next say I know we're doing a um a video
promo shoot in the airport and I'm like
this doesn't happen to normal people do
and you're feeling again you're feeling
blessed and you're thinking this is God
sent and we make that mistake we often
make that mistake even when we're on the
wrong path Satan could still be blessing
us that's right to pull us and lead us
away Y and my cousin was saying look man
you got uh all the girls like King
Solomon you know how to twist about you
got all the free alcohol Jesus turned
water into wine Genesis says every Green
bearing seed he was using scripture to
make me believe keep you in your ways
yeah and I wasn't going to the
scriptures to to counter that so God was
really opening my eyes about the signs
of the times and all this and I so my
plan was I want to move to California
get a good reputation with the world and
then when they look up to me I'll I'll
tell them about prophecy and all that
but God knew that I would just get
sucked into that world models and all
this stuff and so when I came back from
California and got back to
Chattanooga um it was like God drew a
line in the sand and he said if you
pursue this it will happen you see the
sponsorships beers were giving us the
companies were giving us free
beer it kept running into celebrities
everywhere everything laid at your feet
everything was happening and he said if
you pursue this it will happen or you
can lay it all down and follow what I
have for you and and it made me think of
the fishermen that had the biggest Catch
of the Day
and Jesus says no drop it all and follow
me and so at that moment I chose you
became Fisher of man that's right for
the Lord and at that moment I chose to
not go to California to give up this
whole dream and to surrender everything
to God and it was a scary thing to do
because I'm like you gave me these gifts
you gave me the gift of You Know video
editing and graphics and clothing and
even like being on stage and all these
things but never be afraid to surrender
everything because God has something big
bigger for you yes he gave me those
gifts but I was using them for the world
and the moment I surrendered he gave me
Supernatural victory over addiction he
started open up doors in Ministry and
now I'm in a Ministry where I do edit
videos I do still make graphics for
t-shirts and I still get invited place
to place and go and I'm on stage but I'm
not glorifying myself I'm glorifying God
and praising him for what he's done He
blesses us richly abundantly he doesn't
stop he knows us better than we know our
he knows the desires of our heart better
than we know ourselves and I never
dreamed that he could do the things that
he does but when you surrender he'll do
it so we're starting to wind down here
what are your last thoughts that you
want to leave our audience with yeah I
would just say you know when you see
somebody that looks different than you
don't judge them you don't know where
they're at and what God's doing in their
life and don't be afraid to share the
truth of them you know share the truth
in love and for me it wasn't Christians
saying hey what you're doing is wrong it
was them loving me and open up the Bible
and the Bible spoke to my heart it's
like a a sharp two-edged sword and I
began to be transformed by the word of
God and another thing is don't ever give
up on your lost family and friends
they're they're just on a prodical
journey and God's taught me so much
recently about the power of intercessory
prayer your prayers are being heard and
God really is looking for people to
stand in the Gap and intercede for your
lost loved ones well planted seeds
you're coming back right that's right
our culture has been obsessed with
celebrities media and being entertained
studies report that the typical cell
phone user touches the phone 2600 times
every day imagine if we were to touch
the pages of the Bible and ingest
life-saving knowledge 2600 times a day
by using our devices consciously we can
co- labor with Christ to reach the world
make sure sure to share this program
with others until next time this has
been a wolf in sheep's clothing with
blessings
[Music]
[Applause]
win
[Music]